erica i have a composite of someone i'd
like you to have coach
cool so we'll give her the name of
crystal
and she has wonderful ideas which she
puts in notebooks she's written five
screenplays
but she ultimately feels like an
imposter
especially since she hasn't been able to
get any producers
interested in her work and she's had no
luck with screenwriting contests
her goal is to be a hollywood
screenwriter crystal has always done
incredibly well at
everything she's undertaken she's a
perfectionist
somewhat competitive but her sense of
self-worth is
wrapped up in always being the best and
always winning which she's usually been
successful at she's feeling more and
more that maybe
her work isn't creative and interesting
enough
and it's not original possibly so she's
feeling useless and maybe that she
should stop quote-unquote wasting her
time
trying to pursue this career but she
doesn't know what else to do
so how would you begin to work with
crystal crystal
let's do this um
well the very first question i would ask
her and i do have a process that i take
my clients through that i'll share with
you but the very
first question i would ask crystal is do
you want to quit
right she's talking about potentially
throwing in the towel
she doesn't think her her work is
getting her where she needs to go or
where she wants to go and so she's
considering doing something else
is that a true desire or is it
i don't feel like i'm good enough i feel
like i've failed therefore i should do
something else
you know i think i joked with one of my
clients because the other day she had a
moment of like oh i want to quit
you know i think so many of our artists
feel that from time to time on their
journey
and then um last week she got
a very incredible audition opportunity
and she was really excited about it and
she put so much work into it
and my whole comment to her was oh so
you don't want to quit
[Laughter]
so i i i but so i it's like somewhat of
a rhetorical question because i think i
know the answer is like no i don't want
to quit but i do think it's important
for someone to say that out loud
you know to someone for someone to
really be honest and come to terms with
what you truly desire
i mean if you truly do desire to quit
and try something else that's okay too
but
then we don't need to work together
right so i think number one
is really asking crystal
is this something that you want to keep
doing like do you still have that
whisper
is that dream still calling to you is
that why you're coming to me probably
you know so i think that's like
important to establish
right off the bat and then before
we dive into strategy and what's working
and what's not working and what are new
strategies you could be doing
i spend the first usually hour and a
half
with my clients on what
is their belief system what are the
fears and doubts that are really
holding you back and i actually go
through this in my book as well
you know my book kind of goes through a
lot of the things that i do with my
clients so
the first thing i will ask crystal is
what do you want
so you say you want to be a hollywood
screenwriter what does that look like
do you want to sell scripts do you want
to be a staffed writer
on a show do you want to be a show
creator
um what what does that really look like
for you like what is your dream do you
want to be winning emmys
you want to be working on features and
so
i want to hear about it i want to
reconnect to her dream i want to hear
everything that she wants and i would
ask her like write a bulleted list of
everything you desire and we're just
going to put out of our heads right now
that
maybe we don't think it's possible we
have no idea it's not really happening
just
put all of that out of your head right
now i just want to know what do
you want if you could have your dream
what is it that you desire
because once we get really clear on what
it is that she wants that
can really help us form a better
strategy that's going to be more
tailored to what she actually desires
right instead of creating a strategy
based off of what other people are doing
right i could easily go oh crystal you
want to be a screenwriter here's the
screenwriter path let's do this
no i want to know what are her specific
dreams maybe she even has specific
dreams of
certain types of stories or certain
genres you know like i've worked with
some screenwriters who are
super into the horror genre and that's
all they want to do so i want to hear
about it
um and so once she writes this list of
everything that she desires then i go
okay
now tell me every doubt and fear you
have about that list
and we really need to examine what are
the beliefs in your mind right now in
relation to this dream that you're
trying to make happen
because that belief system
is going to control what you do next or
what you've been doing
right you know like for example when you
said
she hasn't had any luck with producers
my question would be how
many did you ask if
you don't believe your success is
inevitable that list is probably five to
ten people
long my clients are emailing 250 people
right and so your belief system behind
everything
is going to control the actions you take
and then
inevitably the opportunities you get
from those actions
you know like a lot of people and i i've
struggled with this myself
um a lot of us we stop short because we
think it's not working
or we feel rejected or we feel
discouraged and so we're not
really going the extra mile you know
we're not
really taking those risks we're not
really doing everything we could be
doing
because we feel deflated and that you
know
those discouraged beliefs um they will
impact the lack of action that's
happening
so i would take her through
uh that list and i would want to hear
what what's every default
fear it's going to say fear and doubt in
the same word what is every fear what is
every doubt that comes
up for you when you look at this list
and then we take every fear on that list
and we flip it to create an affirmation
so that
your new belief system becomes the
opposite of what you believed
so for example if crystal's like well i
have a fear that this will never work
out for me
okay what do you wish you believed
well i'm being crystal here well
i wish that i believed that it would
definitely work out
okay that becomes the new belief
my success is inevitable right and so
we're flipping the fears
and so then at the end you have these
two lists side by side you've got all
the fears and doubts
and then you've got the opposite you
know essentially affirmations of the new
beliefs
and i always say when you look at these
two lists side by side
if you looked at them as two different
people person a and person b
what kind of career would person a have
with this list of fears and doubts
that's their belief system what kind of
career do you think they're going to
have
and it's usually well they probably
won't get very far they're probably
going to struggle
and then what about person b these
affirmations these new beliefs what kind
of career do you think they're going to
have
and you know it's usually they're going
to kick butt
they're going to do great and and the
whole point of this is not to say
you can never have these fears again you
know i think the doubts and the fears
they're always going to be there
they might change over time but the
point is we want
the second list to be in the driver's
seat so the fears and doubts it's okay
to have them
they're still going to hang out in the
back seat of the car but we want the
affirmations the new list the new
beliefs driving the show
and once you build that foundation and
you really get clear about
the belief system that you currently
have and you know the belief system that
you really need to move forward
then we can start to examine the
strategy then i want to know
like crystal okay tell me how many
producers you've
reached out to tell me how many agents
and managers you've reached out to have
you tried to get representation
tell me you know tell me about i want to
hear everything that she's done
and we can take a look about okay well
here's what i think a better strategy
would be for you based on what you told
me you desire right and then we can
build a new strategy from there but what
i find you know especially you said
that crystal is perfectionist and i just
got to do a clubhouse the other day with
someone who specializes in perfectionism
and i really learned a lot
um you know perfectionism holds us back
it's definitely one of those things that
holds us back you know what we fear
and she was saying a lot of times it's
also tied to self-worth like we
we think that we're only worthy if we're
perfect
if our work is perfect and if i feel
like
my work isn't perfect then i'm not
worthy and if i never put my work out
there or take the risks with my work
that i really need to be taking
i don't have to confront whether i'm
worthy or not
right so tying your self-worth to
perfectionism
we would dive deep you know into all of
those things and
take a look and you know the other thing
i would say i just wanted to add
because you mentioned the festivals
there is no one way to succeed in
hollywood
right and so if festivals is one door
that you're knocking on
it's okay if it's not leading anywhere
there are still
a million other doors that you can knock
on so i don't think that any single
door is the be-all end-all you know we
don't have to create the story in our
mind and that's what we do
when we have a rejection we create a
story in our mind about what it means
so i would want to know hey crystal you
haven't succeeded with festivals what
are you telling yourself that that means
so you know really diving deep into how
you feel about what's been happening and
how we can
work on changing it if that makes sense
it does
do you think people that fail are too
busy saying no
or to be busy saying yes because you
know how shonda rhimes talked about she
had a yearbook
yes yeah and i think that's great so so
but but in some ways you could say yes
to things that could
give you busy work too but do you think
as a rule though most people who failed
they haven't said yes enough
i don't think i don't think i would cat
like i usually
don't like to make blanket statements
over things like that i call it
absolutes you know saying all ways or
never
because i don't think anything is the
same for everybody um
so i think some people have trouble
saying no and some people have
you know trouble saying yes uh and it
just
you know has to do with your specific
situation you know i had a client
who had she was an actress and she
already booked a lot of television she
had
like 50 or so episodes already under her
belt um at the co-star of co-star
recurring level maybe one or two guest
stars i forget
maybe it's just all co-stars and she
really wanted to work on
her next level and so we worked on she
ended up getting new representation but
one of the biggest things i worked with
her
on once she got this higher level
representation
was saying no to auditions and really
getting clear
about what her next level looks like and
and what she wants to say yes to and
what she doesn't want to do anymore you
know what was part of her old level
so i think i think either way i think
people hold themselves back
with the yes and the no
you